hi guys um so look at this this is a
different hotel room
I am a Montreal for the Montreal Just
for Laughs festival which is a comedy
festival and it's usually for stand-up
comedians and sketch comedians and
comedians in general this year they've
added an interactive element and myself
Ben reless epiclloyd and Shane Dawson
all did a panel today about is the
internet the new future of comedy and it
was a lot of money and since me
leveraging social media talk so it was
great super fun time but now I am excuse
me I am drinking a vodka soda it's it
and editing my video for tomorrow and I
have my room I just want to show you
guys like this dramatic look can you see
everything that's happening down there
yes there's some concert happening in a
bubble and then there's like circus
stuff that's going on
I can't zoom on this but like
yeah they sound real good um but I'm
probably gonna go down first and get
more drinks at the bar this is I'm done
this but yeah in Montreal go back to New
York tomorrow I was just in LA or the
deck of the show my brain does not know
what time it is man wearing a dress as a
shirt wearing a dress as a shirt okay
how's this music even copy written if
you can't hear anything but bass there
might be some sort of insane clown posse
thing happening but version Canada is
crazy by